so each weapon has a range particular to
it there's some modification you can do
to the range depending on your footwork
your weight shifting but there is a
ceiling to it and the floor to it it's a
place where cheese into the efficiency
go outside of that the efficiency goes
down and the weapon may actually be a
detriment to what I'm doing okay so if
you look at it I have any longer range
weapon than he does his arm is longer
than mine
punch you see that could happen the same
generally is to his advantage if we were
empty hand fighting to keep me at his
arm length it's in my decision
to stay it is our life he said my
advantage to get inside his arm length
which would be my arm length so often
times shorter fighters have to learn how
to get in pass a lead jab or front kick
for example this set is the kind of
narrative that's also teaching these
strategy not just tactics so my strategy
is to keep him out his strategy is to
get in what is the ceiling and the floor
then if he comes so far in he has to
watch the backside of my weapon okay if
he comes so far in he has to watch my
empty hand weapons I will also have to
worry about that ok so as we are doing
my weapon don't don't move ok he's there
and oh that's where I want to be ok I
don't want to be here when I do this
hey hey so as he moves i'm keeping his
weapon out of range you see and stay out
of range of this support weapons we go
on come on come over here I'm enraged
for his support winners now I go like
this I'm in his range so I have to find
again that happy medium where he knows
he won't have time to close the gap with
his support weapons denying that my
ideal range not this so I have to be in
the right place let's go okay he goes
and this same thing he has to be at this
range not close the gap when I come in
he must motivate me by in a way not
knowing me motivate me to stay with the
weapon never motivate me to go to the
other words that would be the floor okay
so pay attention fight it your range
which is not his range and don't get so
close that they're not motivated to go
to the support weapons keep them with
the weapon otherwise your checks don't
do
okay Josiah never gonna take off always
is basically an empty hand
it's a Stockton I hit he never gets full
strike hey I'm not going he pulls over
no no I did smother all his strikes at
the source I'm gonna keep pressing him
without going into his support levels
he's going to be tempted the more I shut
down his weapon the more he's gonna look
for his support weapons it's not
uncommon even an empty hand fighting to
F all of this ballistic dodging and just
smother so when he feels he can't get it
off if you're closing the gap too much
you're looking at a grappling situation
shut it down without over penetrate
[Music]
okay third point duty is the cross
because the 10 character in Chinese
scrip is across okay Zhu Jie in Japanese
its you hear it a lot in Aikido East
Asian martial arts it represents a yin
and Yan you can see that it is okay but
this point in the middle which one is it
is the gender is it young okay it's that
transition point what I'm trying to do
is the early chapters of the daodejing I
have a unity arm before there was a
union Yong
there is the unnameable down okay I call
it down there is a reconciliation of the
Union Yong you get it so when I take
this cross
what I'm going to do is turn the cross
so we get like that and if this boss is
a clash but this cross that hits and
turns is now not across and I can do
that at that contact point you're at
that cross the first cross is here hey
Morton I'm not going in here this is not
Marshall Lee sound because my margin for
error is very small
I'm over here I feel the pressure and I
go around it it's very very slight but
it's there why you see not that bold
well his terrifying writing style
whoa you see okay let's try it let's say
he punted that you have to punch at me
and then he's gonna dance out
did I have to do anything am i safe
because okay that's not what's happening
but it's what tends to happen because
you practice a form not the strategy the
strategy is violence of action it's the
same strategy abstractly related or
abstractly represented to talk to do
I'm not sitting there I penetrated this
is this keeps going
he's does his first name boom and he's
going to keep attacking don't retreat
keep it aggression so forget my moves
one turn the weapon turn the weapon move
right turn it
keep back keep occupied with all of my
intentions and then it makes his offence
harder to do okay that's my joke
strategy so we're going to just drill
the intention one keep going whoa but
I'm not going like this one you see what
did I do
punch me in the face Oh what'd I do
I'm in the support rings so out easy
smooth out boom oh that's your drill on
mindset
are you mother
hold your posture
so I have to set up my own conflict and
he must reconcile okay so in the first
move you have your juji juji oh he has
to deal with that he goes round I have
my duty here Suzy here then I'm gonna
give him one
[Music]
there's the Judas slower and I'm going
to give him another one right there
his strategy his sword cuts targeted
taking advantage of speed it's what sets
up my crosses that and as I do that with
the job and I reconcile at the same way
he goes boom save there it is right
there
reconcile the same way boom boom here it
comes again
right here you see
but if you just does that and I don't do
anything now this one did what I wanted
to get on the inside establishing of the
cross the first process of culture that
generates the IEP which is turning them
across
[Music]
okay it's the same thing there's the
cross come around one here's the cross
you see okay this this one I do it this
way
wait stay there he's gonna go up and I'm
gonna take this cross this way on the
other ones I've taken together okay I
need to feel it in myself so slow it
down again this process this way this
side boom
this cost began to that again almost
this cross was the other way this is
coming here and I'm going to this
that point where they touch I don't add
to it that's what we say stays at that
same pressures zero pressure I need to
come push on old records I'll keep your
attention your attention this year so
reconcile boom boom reconciled boom here
we go
go around go around this point where you
Ford to go up wool laughing I'm not used
to range of my weapon if I might have
Joe come like this I'm not in the range
if I won I have this day a dirty joke
sometimes in our eagerness we start
going to see going to know
oh you got stuck
[Applause]
[Music]
stay there